hi there now that you've learned about
the products and services offered by AWS
let us talk about designing cloud
architecture designing IT infrastructure
for the cloud is completely different
than for traditional on-premise data
centers before the advent of cloud
computing planning your infrastructure
involved making a series of estimates
and educated guesses to determine the
capacity requirements of your products
and applications this often resulted in
serious over or under estimations with
AWS you get to rethink your approach to
architecting an IT environment so you
can take full advantage of cloud
computing this lesson covers how cloud
has brought in an entirely new way to
build IT environments and how one can
achieve it using the AWS recommended
best practices
you
in this lesson you'll learn why building
cloud services requires a different
mindset to that of traditional
on-premise infrastructure you'll be able
to define the key points in the AWS well
architected framework and understand the
four pillars that make up this framework
you'll learn about the key principles
involved in planning and designing cloud
infrastructure you'll have an
understanding of the tools available to
enable AWS monitoring and logging and
you'll also have knowledge on the tools
and functionality available to run
hybrid cloud infrastructure this is the
how to design cloud services section
where we'll take an overview of the AWS
cloud design principles
in the topic how to design cloud
services we will take a look at the AWS
well architected framework and we'll
take a deeper look at the four pillars
which make up the framework and these
are security reliability performance
efficiency and cost optimization
we'll then take a look at where you can
find more information about designing
cloud services for Amazon and we'll will
look at the AWS QuickStart reference
deployments and where you can find out
real-life examples about how real
businesses are using Amazon Web Services
so let's start by looking at the AWS
well architected framework now this was
introduced because building cloud
infrastructure services is vastly
different to what you're used to with
on-premise infrastructure so AWS created
this framework to help you understand
the pros and cons decisions you make
while building systems on AWS the AWS
framework documents are set the
foundation questions that allow you to
understand if a specific architecture
aligns well with the cloud best
practices and there's five principles it
helps you with the first of which is
stop guessing your capacity needs test
systems are production scale lower the
risk of architecture change automate to
make architecture experimentation easier
and allow for evolutionary architectures
and we'll take a look at each of these
in greater detail so firstly let's take
a look at stop guessing your capacity
needs now imagine you're designing a
brand new application for your business
all the infrastructure decisions you
will make and made using estimates which
are basically guesses if you
overestimate you might end up buying too
much hardware and have a fleet of
expensive idle resources conversely you
might underestimate and have to deal
with the performance implications of
limited capacity with cloud computing
these problems go away is AWS helps you
eliminate the guesswork in your
infrastructure capacity needs you can
use as much or as little capacity
you need and scale up and down
automatically depending on your demand
the cloud allows you to test systems of
production scale traditionally in a non
cloud environment is usually very
difficult to fully test new products or
services in development as its cost
prohibitive to have like the like
environments where you just don't have
the resources available personally I've
lost count how many projects have worked
on when things have gone wrong as soon
as the products gone live due to
insufficient testing with the cloud you
can duplicate environments on demand and
when you've completed your testing just
shut them down and you only have to pay
for the time the test environment was up
and running so you can test fully before
you go live in production
AWS allows you to lower the risk of
architecture change as you can automate
the creation of test environments so you
can emulate your production
configurations and carry out testing
against comparable environments you can
also remove testing bottlenecks where
various teams are lining up to use your
test environments as with AWS
you can cheaply spin up as many test
environments as you need and ensure that
all the production changes have been
sufficiently tested
you can automate to make architecture
experimentation easier if you need to
make a change to production but not sure
what the impact will be well you can
automate the creation and replication of
your systems at low cost and low effort
to test these changes you can then audit
the impact and then if necessary you can
revert the changes and try again
with AWS you can allow for evolutionary
architectures in a traditional
environment architecture decisions are
often implemented as a static one-time
event you have to live with during the
lifetime of a system but with a cloud
the capability exists to automate and
test on-demand to lower the risk of
design changes so you can implement new
innovations and features easily what
this means is you aren't stuck with last
year's technology and you can implement
new technology as soon as it comes out
as mentioned earlier the world
architected framework is based on four
pillars security reliability performance
efficiency and cost optimization so in
the coming slides we're going to take a
further look at these four pillars
starting with security
so Amazon defined security as the
ability to protect information systems
and assets while delivering businesses
value through risk assessments and
mitigation strategies
what this means is you can apply
security at all layers so rather than
just running minimal security like
firewalls at the edge of your
infrastructure you can use firewalls and
other security controls on all of your
resources for example security groups on
ec2 instances allow you to define who
and what can access that specific
resource rather than just defining it at
a global infrastructure level you can
enable traceability so you can log and
audit all changes to your environment
you can automate responses to security
events you can monitor and automatically
trigger alerts depending on your needs
you can focus on sharing your system the
AWS shared responsibility model allows
you to focus on securing your
application data and operating systems
whilst AWS secures your infrastructure
and services and you can automate
security best practices AWS allows you
to create and save a custom baseline
image of a virtual server and then you
can use that image to automatically
launch new servers this way you can
ensure that all new resources adhere to
your security standards
so I just briefly mentions the AWS
shared responsibility model now we take
a look at this in more depth in a later
lesson but what it means is that the AWS
shared responsibility model allows AWS
customers to focus on using services to
accomplish their security and compliance
goals because AWS physically secures the
infrastructure that supports your cloud
services so if you look at this diagram
you can see it's split into two security
measures that the cloud service provider
implements and operates is the security
of the cloud and that's a responsibility
of AWS then this is security measures
that the customer inputs and operates
and this is related to the security of
customer content and applications that
make use of the AWS services and this is
security in the cloud and this is a
responsibility of you
so let's take a look at security in the
cloud and this is composed of four areas
data protection privilege management
infrastructure protection and detective
controls
let's start with data protection before
architecting any system practices that
ensure security should be in place with
data protection these are categorizing
data based on levels of sensitivity
granting lease privilege or still
allowing users to perform their work an
encryption to protect your sensitive
data if you're storing customer credit
card data obviously this needs to be
categorized as sensitive and it needs to
be encrypted but log files from a daily
maintenance task wouldn't need this
level of security now there's a number
of tools AWS offers to assist you with
this AWS makes it easy to encrypt data
and manage keys and key rotation using I
am and key management service you can
perform detailed logging using cloud
trail and AWS offers resilient storage
systems like Amazon s3 which has 11 9
secure ability now other lines of
durability means that if you store
10,000 objects with Amazon s3 on average
you can expect to incur a loss of a
single object once every 10 million
years - in other words you're not going
to lose many files and finally AWS
offers versioning and lifecycle
management again with s3 so you can
protect to get accidentally deletes or
file over writes now a central part of
any information security program is
privilege management so that you can
ensure that only authorized and
authenticated users are able to access
your resources and that they can only
access them in a way that is acceptable
for example if a user needs access to a
resource don't just give them admin or
read/write permissions by default
because they might actually only need
read-only access now to control your
privilege management you need to have a
few things in place the first of which
is an access control list and this is a
document that needs to be maintained
which lists access permissions attached
to an object so if you have some
particular documents you need to define
what access is allowed to it then you
have role based access controls and this
defines the permissions for a particular
to the end-users role or function so an
administrator would obviously need
administrator access to various
resources but you know a date a regular
end-user might only need read-only
access so you need to define which roles
have which permissions then this
password management and this includes
complexity requirements and change
intervals so you define how often people
need to change their passwords and how
complex they need to be now Amazon helps
you with all this with the Identity and
Access Management or I am service and
this is the primary service used to
control access to AWS services and
resources we cover I am in huge detail
in a later lesson but briefly it allows
you to apply granular policies which
assign permissions to users groups roles
or resources and you can also control
the password strength using this as well
as Federation which are existing
directory services such as Microsoft
Active Directory
we also need to protect your
infrastructure and to do this it's
recommended to have multiple layers of
Defense and also multi-factor
authentication to meet best practices
with industry or regulatory obligations
now Amazon allows you to do this by
implementing stateful or stateless
packet inspection
evie using AWS native technologies or by
using partner products and services
available through the AWS marketplace
Amazon virtual cloud VPC enforces
boundary protection and monitoring
points of ingress and egress and then
this cloud trail and cloud watch which
provides comprehensive logging
monitoring and alerting
you should always have detective
controls in place so you can detect or
identify security breaches this needs to
happen so you can provide both a quality
support process and meet compliance
obligation and buy a quality support
process I mean one in which when you
have a problem you're committed to
finding out the root cause and actually
resolving the issue rather than just
saying oh we think it was that let's
hope it doesn't happen again
I mean I know I've worked for some
places like that and it's a certainly
not quality support process AWS helps
you with your detective controls by
providing these services AWS cloud trail
is a service that logs API tools so you
can find out the identity of callers the
time of calls source IP addresses and
things like that so you can find out who
is doing what and when Amazon CloudWatch
is a monitoring service for AWS
resources so you can log ec2 CPU usage
or network activity and you can use
cloud watch with many different services
like RDS EBS and more you can also set
up alarms so you can be notified when
certain things happen
AWS config is an inventory and
configuration history service that
provides information about the
configurations and changes in
infrastructure over time with Amazon s3
you can see to access all the ting so
you can find out who has been accessing
your s3 data and who when they did it
and when and Amazon Glacia you can use
the vault lock feature to preserve
mission-critical data with compliance
controls that are designed to be
auditable for long term retention the
next pillar is reliability and Amazon
defines this as the ability of a system
to recover from infrastructure or
service failures by Namek the acquire
computing resources to meet demand and
mitigate disruptions such as miss
configurations or transient network
issues with reliability in the cloud
there's a number of things to look at
firstly you can test recovery procedures
cloud infrastructure means you can test
how your system fails and you can
validate your recovery strategy places
I've worked at in the past there's asked
to recover
he was a big event it was only done
annually it took months of preparation
it involved working a whole weekend and
then some and was also incredibly
disruptive to the business imagine being
able to duplicate your production
environment and test failure and
failover whenever you want you can
automatically recover from failure with
the cloud monitoring a system for a key
performance indicator or KPI you can
automatically trigger automated recovery
processes when a threshold is breached
you can scale horizontally to increase
aggregate system availability using
multiple small resources instead of one
large resource will reduce your single
points of failure and also you can stop
guessing capacity gone are the days of
using lack of memory or not enough CPU
is a failure for a resource with the
cloud you can scale as and when you need
to so you can't blame badly estimated
capacity is the reason for reliability
issues
now reliability in the cloud is composed
of three areas these are foundations
change management and failure management
to achieve reliability a system must
have a well-planned Foundation and
monitoring in place plus systems for
handling changes in demand or
requirements is also required in an
ideal world your system would be
designed to detect failure and
automatically heal itself before
architecting any system you should have
foundations in place so that your
reliability is not impacted you should
have sufficient network bandwidth to
your data center you should have
sufficient compute capacity your staff
should be trained in the areas they need
to be and you should have support
contracts with your vendors with AWS
network bandwidth and compute capacity
is already taken care of AWS also offers
a range of support contracts to help you
with issues and a range of training
courses for your staff change management
is a critical part being aware of how a
change affects a system allows you to
plan proactive and monitoring allows you
to quickly identify trends that could
lead to capacity issues or SLA breaches
with AWS you can monitor the behavior of
a system and automate the response to
KPIs for example you can add additional
servers as a system gains more users so
you can control who has permissions to
make system changes and audit the
history of these changes unfortunately
it's a given that failures will occur so
you need to have some failure management
in place is good practice to understand
why things failed so you can prevent it
from happening again
no one wants to work for a company that
when things go wrong they just get it
working again with no understanding of
why a key to managing failure is
frequent and automated testing of
systems to failure and through recovery
ideally you do this on a regular
schedule and also after you've made
significant system changes now Amazon
allows you to do this with a few
products firstly AWS CloudFormation
this allows you to launch temporary
copies of whole systems a very low cost
so you can use automated testing
verify your recovery processes you can
use cloud watch to set up automation to
react to monitoring data that indicates
a failure and you can store all your
data on Amazon s3 buckets for future use
the next pillar is performance
efficiency and Amazon defines this as
the ability to use computing resources
efficiently to meet system requirements
and to maintain the efficiency as demand
changes and technologies evolve so what
does this mean well performance
efficiency in the cloud means you can
democratize advanced technologies AWS
provides products such as no SQL or
media transcoding or even machine
learning as a service so rather than
your IT team having to learn how to host
and run these new technologies AWS does
it for you you can go global in minutes
AWS allows you to easily deploy your
systems in multiple regions around the
world with just a few clicks of your
mouse so this leads to lower latency for
your customers you can use serverless
architectures in the cloud which remove
the need for you to run and maintain
servers to carry out traditional compute
activities for example storage services
can act as static websites which remove
the need for web servers and you can
also use serverless technologies such as
lambda or elastic beanstalk and you can
also experiment more often with virtual
and automatable resources you can
quickly carry comparative testing using
different types of instances storage or
configuration so performance efficiency
in the cloud is composed of four areas
compute storage database and something
called space-time trade-off and let's
take a look at each of these with the
cloud finding the optimal server
configuration for a product will vary
based on application design usage
patterns and configuration settings
traditional IT infrastructure requires
making estimates in advance which can
lead to incorrect server configurations
and lower performance efficiency AWS is
virtualized so you can quickly change
the ec2 server configuration to increase
its performance efficiency it may be
optimal to run serverless computing for
example AWS lambda allows you to execute
code without running an instanced an
elastic Beanstalk allows you to run web
applications in a similar manner from an
operational standpoint you should have
monitoring in place to notify you of any
degradation in performance the optimal
storage solution for a particular system
will vary based on whether you need
block file or object storage the type of
throughput required frequency of access
and availability and durability
constraints
well architected systems use multiple
storage solutions and enable different
features to improve performance in AWS
Storage is virtualized and is available
in a number of different types this
makes it easier to match your storage
methods more closely with your needs and
also offers storage options that are not
easily achievable with on-premise
infrastructure for example Amazon s3 is
time for 1190 or ability and provides a
variety of storage classes field
different data categories like Glacia
for archived data EBS and EFS offer
numerous options for your ec2 instances
based on the level of performance you
require from your storage the optimal
database solution for a particular
system can vary based on requirements
for consistency availability partition
tolerance and latency
many systems use different database
solutions for various subsystems and
enable different features to improve
performance selecting the wrong database
solution and features for a system can
lead to much lower performance
efficiency now for database usage you
need to go to monitor them test them and
also you need to have some database
platform knowledge but Amazon makes this
much easier for you as it provides a
suite of Amazon relational database
services which are fully managed
relational databases for example Amazon
DynamoDB is a fully managed no SQL
database that provides single digit
millisecond latency at any scale Amazon
redshift is a managed petabyte scale
data warehouse that allows you to
the number or type of nodes is your
performance or capacity needs change you
can also make use of Aurora or a.m. is
where you install your own databases
from templates so what is the space-time
trade-off where you can think of space
as memory or storage and you can think
of time as the processing time or the
compute time to complete a task
so when you're architecting solutions
there's always a series of trade-offs
where it might be better to have more
memory or storage to reduce the
processing time or maybe you're happy to
sacrifice the processing time in order
to reduce your memory of storage
requirements AWS gives you the option to
maximize one or the other for example
you could launch your systems globally
so you're increasing space in memory so
that they're closer to the end users in
order to reduce latency all the time but
whatever resource you use you need to
have monitoring in place to notify you
of any degradation in performance and
the final pillar of the well architected
framework is cost optimization this is
defined as the ability to avoid or
eliminate unneeded cost or sub optimal
resources AWS cloud has a number of ways
you can provide cost optimization
firstly you can transparently attribute
expenditure as the cloud makes it easy
to identify the costs of a system an
attribute IT cost of individual business
owners so those owners will have an
incentive to optimize their resources
and reduce costs you can use managed
services to remove the operational
burden of maintaining servers for tasks
such as sending email or managing
databases you can trade capital expense
for operating expense instead of
investing heavily in data centers and
servers before you know how you're going
to use them with AWS you pay only for
the computing resources you consume when
you consume them also AWS allows you to
achieve higher economies of scale
because they can by way more servers and
hardware than you could ever imagine so
it's much cheaper to use their hardware
than by your own you should also stop
spending money on data send
operations AWS is the heavy lifting of
racking stacking empowering servers so
you can focus on your customers and
business projects rather than on your IT
infrastructure cost optimization in the
cloud is composed to four areas match
supply and demand cost-effective
resources expenditure awareness and
optimizing over time matching supply to
demand will deliver the lowest costs for
a system but you'll need to be able to
provide sufficient extra capacity to
cope with demand in failures in AWS you
can automatically provision resources to
match demand auto-scaling time-based and
event-driven and queue based approaches
allow you to add and remove resources as
needed monitoring tools and regular
benchmarking can help you achieve much
greater utilization of your resources
using the appropriate instances and
resources for your system is key to cost
savings for example a reporting process
might take five hours to run on a
smaller server but a larger server that
is twice as expensive might better do it
in just one hour both jobs give you the
same outcome but the smaller server will
occur more costs over time but to be
able to find out these things you need
to have monitoring of expenditure in
place and also regular benchmarking AWS
helps you of this AWS trusted advisor
goes through your resources and tells
you where you can make savings you can
use on-demand instances so you only pay
for compute capacity by the hour with no
minimum commitments required or you
could use reserved instances which allow
you to reserve capacity and offer
savings of up to 75% off on-demand
pricing and with spot instances you can
bid on unused ec2 capacity at
significant discounts you can also take
advantage of managed AWS services such
as RDS or dynamo DB which can also lower
your costs AWS and it's virtually
unlimited on-demand capacity requires a
new way of thinking about expenditures
so you need to have a different way of
budgeting
and you need to understand your business
units usage to do this you can use cost
allocation tags to categorize and track
your AWS costs for AWS resources such as
ec2 or Amazon s3 an AWS generates a cost
allocation report with your usage and
costs aggregated by your tags so you can
set up tags for each of your business
categories and units this increased
visibility of costs makes it easier to
identify resources or projects that are
no longer generating value and should be
decommissioned billing alerts can be set
up to notify you of predicted overspend
and the AWS simple monthly calculator
allows you to calculate data transfer
costs and you can set up SNS alerts so
you can be notified when certain
resources or cost breaches occur
optimizing over time is an important
strategy to reduce your costs associated
with your cloud environment AWS is
always releasing new products and
services as such you need to reassess
your existing setup to see if it's the
most cost effective for example rather
than running a database on an ec2
instance it might be cheaper to run an
Amazon RDS database or lambda might be
more cost effective than ec2 but where'd
you find out more information about
these new products and services from
Amazon well the first place to look for
any new architecture guide is the AWS
architecture center this is a resource
that provides you with the guidance and
application architecture best practices
to build highly scalable and reliable
applications in the cloud here you'll
find the AWS reference architectures the
AWS reference architecture data sheets
provide architectural guidance to help
you build an application on the AWS
cloud you'll find data sheets that
include a description of how each
service is used plus visual
representations of the application
architecture for example web application
hosting or large scale processing and
huge data sets or even building elastic
web front-ends for an e-commerce website
AWS white paper
is provide a comprehensive list of
technical AWS white papers that cover
all Amazon related topics such as
architecture security and economics
there are new white papers being
released all the time and written by
someone emotion knowledgeable AWS people
around AWS Quick Start reference
deployments use AWS CloudFormation
templates to rapidly deploy a fully
functional environment for a variety of
enterprise software applications
supplementary deployment guides describe
the architecture and implementation in
detail in this course we'll deploy
things manually step by step so you can
see how it works but with cloud
formation templates you can do several
hours work with just the click of a
button
examples of cloud formation templates
are SharePoint ID gateway or even sequel
server on Windows Server failover
clusters and finally case studies AWS
maintains a large list of case studies
and success stories from their clients
you can check to see how some of the
largest and most successful companies on
the planet use AWS for their business in
the planning and designing section we'll
take a look at the principles involved
in planning and designing cloud
infrastructure you'll learn how the AWS
well architected framework is used in
planning and designing we'll take a look
at scaling and all the different
versions we'll look at the importance of
loose coupling how you can build
redundancy into your cloud
infrastructure how you can save money by
cost optimization
we'll look at automation and how it can
make management of an IT environment
easier and also we'll take a look at
security how you can secure your cloud
resources so let's start with
scalability in the past you would have
to estimate the peak load of your
systems and purchase your hardware
accordingly so perhaps you were setting
up a new website and you were estimating
that you're going to get a million
people per month hitting your website so
you buy the hardware accordingly
but then you find out that only 50,000
people are hitting it or 10 million
people are hitting it so your hardware
is inappropriate for the work
cloud computing provides virtually
unlimited on-demand capacity so you can
scale whenever you need to to do this
your designs need to be able to
seamlessly take advantage of these
resources and there are two ways to
scale vertically and horizontally
vertical scaling means increasing the
specifications of an individual resource
for example increasing the memory or the
number of CPUs on a server with AWS this
is easily achieved with a restart of
your virtual server so that it resizes
to a larger or smaller instance type the
advantage of this approach is that it's
very easy and requires little fall in
the short term however this type of
scaling can eventually hit a limit and
sometimes be cost inefficient especially
if they scale up to some very very large
instances horizontal scaling means
increasing the number of resources
rather than the specifications of each
individual resource for example adding
additional web servers to help spread
the load of traffic hitting your
application this is a great way to build
applications that leverage the
elasticity of cloud computing however
not all architectures can distribute
their workload to multiple resources a
stateless application is one that needs
no knowledge of previous interaction and
stores no session information an example
of this would be a web server that
provides the same webpage to any end
user a stateless application can scale
horizontally as any request from any end
user can be serviced by any of the
available compute resources you can add
more resources as required and then
remove them when the capacity is no
longer available
stateless applications do not need to be
aware of their peers all that is
required is a way to distribute the
end-user sessions to them and there are
two ways to distribute load the multiple
nodes the first of these is the push
model a load balancer such as the AWS
elastic load balancer is a popular way
to distribute a work load across
multiple resources
an alternative but less recommended
approach is to implement a DNS
round-robin using Amazon route 53 where
DNS responses to return an IP address
from a list of valid hosts in a round
robin fashion this isn't easy to set up
an option but it can cause issues if DNS
records are cached the alternative to
the push model is the pool model
tasks that need to be performed can be
stored as messages in a queue and
multiple compute resources can pull and
process the messages in a distributed
fashion examples of this are big data
processing scenarios where many servers
work to analyze data and return results
or media file conversion processes where
multiple servers convert the files as
they arrive Amazon sqls or Amazon
Kinesis the services that can provide
pull model load balancing most
applications need to maintain some kind
of state information for example an
automated multi-step process will also
need to track previous activity to
decide what its next action should be
you can make components in your
architecture stateless by not storing
anything on the local file system and
instead storing user or session based
information in a database like dynamodb
or MySQL or on shared storage like
Amazon s3 or EFS additionally Amazon SWF
can be used to sent released or
execution history and make your workload
stateless so the opposite stateless
applications are state full applications
as it's not possible to turn some layers
of your architecture into stateless
components for example databases which
are stateful by definition or
applications that were designed to run
on a single server providing multiple
users a consistent view of the database
or application is much simpler when your
components are not distributed
distributing the load is possible though
through session affinity this means that
all transactions of a session are bound
to a specific compute resource
however Smee --nz that existing sessions
would not be able to utilize newly
introduced
notes but also if a node is shut down or
becomes unavailable users bound to that
station will be disconnected for
situations when you need to process
large amounts of data is always
beneficial to see if the distributed
processing approach can be used
imagine a task that requires a huge
amount of data processing if it's to run
on a single computer II source it would
max out the resources and take a long
time to complete you can divide the task
into smaller fragments of work then each
of the tasks can be executed across a
larger set of compute resources examples
of this are the AWS elastic MapReduce
service which allows you to run Hadoop
workloads across multiple ec2 instances
or Amazon Kinesis allows you to run
multiple shards of data on ec2 or lambda
resources for real-time processing of
streaming data the concept of disposable
resources is completely new with cloud
computing as cloud computing completely
changes the mindset of an IT
infrastructure environment traditional
environments involve purchasing Hardware
upfront and required manual
configuration of the software network
etc whereas with cloud computing all
infrastructure is temporary or
disposable you can launch new instances
when you need them and get rid of them
when you are done ultimate compute
resource initiation is a way to speed up
the creation of new environments AWS has
plenty of features to make new
environment creation and automated and
repeatable process and thus three
options available which we'll look at in
the coming slides bootstrapping golden
images and a hybrid approach
bootstrapping means you can take a newly
launched AWS resource with its default
configuration and then execute automated
scripts to install software or copy data
to bring that resource to a required
state so you could launch an ec2
instance and copy data on so that it
becomes a web server scripts can be
parameterized so that different
environments production or development
can be initiated easily with AWS
strapping can be achieved with your own
scripts chef or puppet ops work
lifecycle events or cloud formation
golden images mean you take snapshots of
your ec2 instances or RDS instances or
even EBS volumes and they can be used to
launch new instances these ec2 instances
can also be customized and saved as a
Mis
Amazon machine images and then you can
launch as many instances as you want
from this template if you have an
on-premise virtualized environment you
can also use AWS vm import/export to
create your own AWS am is the hybrid
approach makes use of both bootstrapping
and golden images you can launch new
instances from a golden image but then
bootstrap to configure other actions
basically with AWS you are only
restricted by your own imagination or
coding skills AWS assets are
programmable so you can apply all these
techniques and principles that we've
just talked about to entire environments
and not just individual resources so you
can completely rethink the way you work
for IT infrastructure automation is a
big part of planning and designing cloud
infrastructure AWS allows you to reduce
the level of manual interaction in your
environment using automation you can
react to a variety of events without
having to do anything let's take a look
at some examples AWS elastic Beanstalk
developers can act with their code and
the Beanstalk service automatically
handles resource provisioning
auto-scaling
load balancing and monitoring ec2 auto
recovery in some situations you can use
auto recovery to automatically recover
an ec2 instance if it becomes impaired
the recovered instance is identical to
the original instance name IP address
metadata etc auto scaling you can
automatically add resources to cope with
demand spikes and decrease again during
quiet times cloud watch alarms and
events cloud wars can send SMS
notifications to alert when a particular
event occurs for example CPU usage is
too
hi the notifications can be used to
perform follow-up actions like run a
lambda function opsworks lifecycle
events you can continually update your
instances configuration to adapt to
environment changes for example if a new
database instance is added to your
environment then an event can
automatically trigger a chévre P the
points existing applications to the new
server loose coupling is an important
concept applications should be designed
so that they're broken into smaller
loosely coupled components the desired
outcome is that a failure in one
component should not cause other
components to fail this is achieved for
a variety of measures firstly
well-defined interfaces by ensuring that
all components only interact with each
other through specific technology
agnostic interfaces for example restful
api s will result in being able to
modify resources without affecting other
components Amazon API gateway is a fully
managed service for a pis which you can
do this with loose coupling needs
services to be able to interact with
each other without having any prior
knowledge of their existence for example
imagine two servers communicating on
hard-coded IP addresses then the
addition or modification of resources
will result in manual interaction to
update the configuration however
literally coupled infrastructure is an
essential ingredient in making the most
of cloud computing elasticity the
easiest way to achieve this is to use an
elastic load balancer service to provide
a stable endpoint for all your services
this way they don't have to worry about
each other
the elastic load balancer does that for
them rather than use synchronous
integration where server a completes an
action and passes it to server B which
then passes it to server C asynchronous
integration involves the use of an
intermediate storage area like an S qsq
this approach means that when a server a
completes its action it sends a
notification to sqs this way the compute
resources are decoupled and not directly
to each other this means you can easily
add or remove resources without having
to update the configuration of the
existing compute resources designing
applications to fail gracefully allows
other resources to continue a service
without causing a complete outage
examples of this would be if your
primary website fails the route 53 DNS
failover feature points your users to a
backup site hosted on a static website
on Amazon s3 the idea is to continue to
provide a service even if it isn't the
full experience traditional IT
infrastructure involves developing
managing and operating applications with
a wide variety of underlying technology
components AWS isn't just about ec2
instances there are sweeter products to
do everything mentioned and a lot more
besides
to help you lower your IT costs and
allow you to move faster as an
organization for example managed
services AWS provides many services that
are fully managed databases machine
learning analytics search email etc this
lessens the burden on your IT
infrastructure department RDS databases
mean you don't have to worry about
backups fault tolerance field simple
databases s3 allows you to store as much
data as you need without having to
concern yourself with capacity
management server this architectures you
cannot reduce operational complexity of
your applications for the use of service
architectures tools such as the Internet
of Things lambda s3 Beanstalk all allow
you to run your applications without
paying for any server infrastructure in
a traditional IT environment the type of
database in use is typically restricted
by constraints on licensing support
capabilities hardware availability and
things like that
AWS provides you with multiple managed
database server options that remove
these constraints meaning that you can
choose exactly the right database for
your needs rather than making use of
what is available to you AWS offers
fully managed easy scalable
services for relational databases no SQL
data warehouses and search functions
that provide fully managed easily
scalable services that can create
synchronously replicated and buy
instances in different availability
zones and they'll also automatically
failover without the need for manual
intervention will cover databases in a
whole lesson later on in this course now
we'll take a look at redundancy
introducing redundancy will ensure your
systems are highly available so they can
withstand the failure of individual or
multiple components for example hard
disks servers or network links
introducing redundancy will remove
single points of failure from your
systems this is achieved
having multiple resources for the same
tasks in either standby or active mode
standby redundancy is often used for
stateful components like databases the
standby resource becomes the primary
resource by failing over to it the
standby resource can be brought online
only when required to save cost or it
can already be running to speed up the
failover process and minimize the outage
active redundancy is where multiple
redundant compute resources share
requests and are able to absorb the loss
of one or more of the instances failing
examples of this would be multiple web
servers sitting behind a load balancer
automatic failure detection allows you
to react to an outage automatically
without the need for manual intervention
services like elastic load balancer and
route 53 that you configure health
checks you can automatically route
traffic to healthy resources for example
setting up a health check to test for a
HTTP 200 response which means ok would
allow AWS to know if a node is healthy
or not
services such as opsworks elastic load
balancer an ec2 auto recovery will let
you replace unhealthy resources with
brand-new healthy ones durable data
storage is an important part of planning
or cloud resources replicating your data
to other sites or resources will protect
its availability and integrity there's
three ways you can replicate
data synchronously asynchronously or
quorum based synchronous replication
ensures that your data has been durably
stored on both the primary and
replication locations any right
operation will only be acknowledged as
complete when this has taken place this
should only be used on low latency
network connections where absolutely
necessary to try to ensure maximum
performance asynchronous replication
decouples the primary node from the
replicas so that a write operation
doesn't have to wait for any
acknowledgment this can introduce a
replication lag but does not impact
performance and from personal experience
I've seen the difference between
synchronous and asynchronous replication
changing performance as much as a 100%
quorum based replication is a mix of
both synchronous and asynchronous
replication replication to multiple
nodes is controlled by defining the
minimum number of nodes that must
participate in a successful write
operation so if you have a cluster of 4
replicas you can say I need confirmation
from at least two of them before the
acknowledgement is sent back to the end
user a traditional data center failover
scenario involves failing over all your
resources to a secondary distant data
center because of the long distances
between the two data centers synchronous
replication is often impractical slow
and usually involves data loss and isn't
tested very often however it does
protect against low probability
scenarios such as a natural disaster so
if your main data center is in New York
and your secondary was in say Washington
if New York had a massive outage you
could fail over the Washington but is
going to be slow and practical and take
some time a more likely scenario is a
shorter interruption in your data center
which isn't predicted to be too long in
this situation your choice is to sit it
out and wait or initiate the complex
failover procedure AWS data centers are
configured to provide multiple
availability zones in a region with low
latency network connectivity this means
you can replicate your data across
centers in a synchronous manner and as a
result failover becomes much simpler
also this concept is baked into many AWS
services such as RDS and s3 active
redundancy is great for disaster
recovery situations or balancing traffic
but what if all the requests your
resources were harmful for example if a
particular request caused the bug and it
resulted in multiple instances crashing
a practice called shuffle sharding means
only sending some of the requests to
some of your resources this way if one
shard of resources is infected or down
the other shard of resources will be up
and running in the example shown here if
request 2 is bad then at least one set
of resources is still protected AWS
economies of scale offer organizations
huge opportunities to make cost savings
by making further use of AWS
capabilities there's even more scope to
create cost optimized cloud
architectures right sizing is one such
approach in stark contrast at
traditional IT infrastructure cloud
computing means you can select the most
cost-effective resource and
configuration to fit your requirements
ec2 RDS redshift and elastic search give
you a wide variety of instant types to
choose from through benchmarking you can
determine the optimal configuration for
your workload in some cases it might be
optimal to select many of the cheapest
instant type available in others it
might be more beneficial to select fewer
instances but of a larger instance type
AWS Storage offers the same level of
right sizing opportunities Amazon s3
offers many different storage classes to
suit your needs
EBS also comes in a variety of different
volume types all of which will be
covered in later lessons
AWS offers many elasticity options to
help you save money you can also scale
your ec2 workloads horizontally or
vertically you can turn off production
workloads when you don't need them and
where possible you can use lambda
compute workloads so you never have to
pay for idle resources ec2 on demand the
instance price
Tsing means you only pay for what you
use with no long-term commitments
however there are two more ways to pay
for ec2 instances one of these is
reserved capacity by committing to a
defined period of between 12 to 36
months you can receive significantly
discounted hourly rates compared to on
demand pricing AWS trusted advisor or
AWS ec2 usage reports identify the
resources that would benefit from
reserved capacity there is technically
no difference between on-demand and
reserved instances the only difference
is the way you pay for it this concept
also exists for redshift RDS DynamoDB
and CloudFront ec2 spot instances are
ideal for workloads that have flexible
start and end times as you are allowed
to bid on spare ec2 computing capacity
and spot instances are often available
at significant discounts compared to
on-demand pricing your ec2 spot instance
is launched when your bid exceeds the
current spot market price and it will
continue to run until either you
terminate it or the spot market price
exceeds your bid when the latter happens
your instance is terminated and you'll
not be charged for the partial order
that was running so it's three
strategies to use for spot instances
there's a one we've just discussed which
is bidding you could bid much higher
than the spot market price for as long
as the instant runs this way even if the
market price spikes occasionally you'll
still make a saving overall the mixed
strategy AWS recommends designing
applications that use a mixture of
reserved on demand and spot instances
this way you can combine predictive
capacity with opportunistic access to
cheaper additional compute resources and
then finally the spot blocks AWS allows
you to bid for fixed duration spot
instances these have a different hourly
pricing but allow you to define a
duration requirement if your bid is
accepted your instance will run until
you terminate it or the duration ends
now let's take a look at caching caching
data means storing previously calculated
data for future use so you don't have to
recount
again there's two approaches application
caching you can design applications to
store and retrieve information from fast
managed in-memory caches this way an
application can look for results in the
cache first and if the data isn't there
it can then calculate it or retrieve the
data and store it in the cache for
subsequent requests this approach
approves user response times and reduces
load on your resources an example of
this is Amazon ElastiCache which is a
service that provides an in mem cache in
the cloud suitable for use with web
services edge caching uses Amazon
CloudFront so you can cache static
content such as images or video and
dynamic content such as live video
around the world using edge locations
this way users can be served the content
that is closest Allah and resulting in
low latency response times
the principle applies to both download
and upload with edge caching
and finally security it's important to
have security built into your plans and
designs for AWS infrastructure AWS
allows you to take most of the security
tools and techniques that you already
know and improve them by formalizing
security control design into your AWS
platform this simplifies the system for
administrators and auditors alike
now we're not going to cover too much
here because this is all covered in the
I am lesson but there's things like
defense-in-depth
which allows you to add multiple layers
of protection to your resources reduce
privileged access to only give people
the access they require security as a
code lets you capture security
requirements in one script that you can
use to deploy new environments and real
time auditing AWS has multiple services
to ensure you can test and audit your
environment in real time in this section
we're going to take a look at monitoring
and logging and an overview of the tools
available to enable AWS monitoring and
logging in this section you're going to
learn about Amazon Cloud watch Amazon
Cloud Trail and Amazon config and how
they can be used to monitor and log your
cloud infrastructure so Amazon Cloud
watch monitors your Amazon Web Services
resources and applications in real time
in a particular region it collects and
tracks metrics it uses alarms to send
notifications and you can automatically
make changes to monitored resources
based on defined rules Amazon CloudWatch
events deliver a stream of system events
which alerts about changes that AWS
resources alerts can be sent to services
such as AWS lambda Amazon SNS Amazon sqs
and Amazon Kinesis streams for example
you can monitor the CPU usage and disk
reads and writes of your ec2 compute
cloud instances and you can use this
data to determine whether you should
launch additional instances to handle
the increased load you can also use this
data to stop underused instances and
save money you can also use cloud watch
events to schedule
events such as a snapshot creation or an
instance reboot in addition to the
monitoring with the built-in metrics
that come with AWS you can monitor your
own custom metrics to enable system-wide
visibility into resource utilization
application performance operational
health and even cost you can use Amazon
CloudWatch logs to monitor store and
access your application or system logs
from Amazon ec2 instances AWS cloud
trail or other sources you can then
retrieve the Associated log data from
cloud watch logs so cloud watch has a
number of limits for metrics events and
logs now I'm not going to go into all of
them because there's quite a lot but
some of the key ones are you get 10
cloud watch metrics per customer per
month for free as well there's 10 alarms
per customer per month for free 1
million API requests 1000 Amazon SNS
email notifications there's also no
limit on the number of custom metrics
you can create you can create up to
5,000 alarms per AWS account and your
metric data is kept for two weeks AWS
cloud trail is a web service that
records AWS API calls for your account
the recorded information includes the
identity of the API caller the time of
the API call the source IP address of
the API caller and other request
parameters cloud trail also stores and
delivers log files to you and it
provides a history of AWS API calls for
your account contrail provides increased
visibility so you can answer questions
such as what actions did a given user
take over a given time period or for a
given resource which user has taken
actions on it over a given period of
time what is the source IP address of a
given activity and which activities
failed due to inadequate permissions so
cloud trail will help you when auditors
come asking questions or if you're
trying to solve a problem
it also offers durable and inexpensive
log file store
courage Clairol uses Amazon s3 for log
file storage so log files are stored
durably and inexpensively you can also
use Amazon s3 lifecycle configuration
rules to further reduce storage costs
for example you can define rules to
automatically delete old log files or
archive them to Amazon Glacia for
additional savings Cloud trail is a
fully managed service so no installation
required you turn on Cloud trail for
your account in the AWS management
console and it will start creating cloud
trail log files in an Amazon s3 bucket
that you specify you get notifications
for log file delivery cloud trail uses
the Amazon simple notification service
so that you can be notified when a new
log file is delivered or when a specific
event has occurred also companies such
as Splunk sumo logic or log li offer
integrated solutions to analyze your
cloud trail log files cloud trial can
also be configured to aggregate log
files across multiple accounts and
regions so that log files are delivered
to a single s3 bucket cloud ro
automatically encrypts all log files
delivered to the specified s3 bucket by
using the Amazon s3 server-side
encryption SSE you can also further
secure your log files using the AWS key
management service you can also validate
the integrity of your cloud trail log
files so if you're concerned that an
admin user is trying to cover up his
tracks by deleting entries from the log
files you can see whether the log files
are unchanged modified or have been
deleted since cloud trial delivered them
AWS config is a fully managed service
that provides you with an AWS resource
inventory configuration history and
configuration change notifications you
can automatically check the
configuration of AWS resources by
checking AWS config using config rules
an IT administrator can quickly
determine when and how a resource went
out of compliance for example you can
ensure that your EBS volumes are
encrypted
your ec2 instances are properly tagged
or elastic IP addresses or
two instances and this is all enabled
with a few mouse clicks in the AWS
console ad OS config enables
configuration visibility you can view
all the configuration attributes of your
AWS resources in real time and SNS will
notify you of any updated configuration
or specific changes from the previous
state you can continuously assess the
overall compliance of your AWS resource
configurations based on your
organization's policies and guidelines
AWS config rules give you a visual
dashboard with list charts and graphs to
help you quickly spot non-compliant
resources and take appropriate action
AWS config is also compatible with
third-party applications such as spunk
in this section we're going to take a
look at hybrid IT architectures and have
an overview of the tools and
functionality available to run hybrid
cloud architectures AWS offers a wide
and deep set of functionality that
allows you to integrate your existing
network security data lifecycle
management and resource management
capabilities with the cloud AWS allows
you to extend your existing on-premise
network configuration onto your AWS
virtual private clouds so that your AWS
resources will operate as if they're
part of your existing network you can do
this using Amazon virtual private cloud
VPC which is a logistically isolated
network in the Amazon Cloud that gives
you complete control over your virtual
networking environment you can choose
your own IP range subnets route tables
Network etc then this Direct Connect
rather than use internet-based
connections between your on-site
resources and the Amazon Cloud Direct
Connect lets you establish a dedicated
network connection between the two to
provide lower costs and a higher level
of service you can use AWS to reliably
and cost-effectively backup and secure
your data AWS allows you to replicate
your data across geographical regions
manage the lifecycle of the data or even
synchronously replicate your data to a
local AWS data center
AWS Storage Gateway is a VM that you
install in your data center and
configure to be associated with your AWS
account then you can either use Gateway
cached which it lets you use Amazon s3
storage is your primary data storage
while retaining frequently accessed data
locally in your storage gateway or
gateway stored gateway stored volumes
that you store the primary data locally
and asynchronously back that up to AWS
Amazon simple storage service s3 offers
a practically unlimited storage that's
available for backing up and archiving
your critical data and Amazon Glacia is
extremely local storage for infrequently
access data for which recovery intervals
for several hours are suitable AWS
security and access control is easily
managed using I am or Microsoft Active
Directory services AWS Identity and
Access Management is the service that
enables you to securely control user
access to all your AWS services and
resources an AWS directory service is a
managed service that allows you to
connect your AWS resources with an
existing on-premise Microsoft Active
Directory or you can set up a new
standalone directory in the AWS cloud
AWS security and access control is
easily managed using I am or Microsoft
Active Directory services AWS Identity
and Access Management is the service
that enables you to securely control
user access to all your AWS services and
resources an AWS directory service is a
managed service that allows you to
connect your AWS resources of an
existing on-premise Microsoft Active
Directory or you can set up a new
standalone directory in the AWS cloud
and thus three flavors of Active
Directory as Microsoft ad which is a
fully blown managed Microsoft Active
Directory service that supports up to
50,000 users the simple ad which is a
standalone managed directory that's
available in two sizes small and large
small is for up to 500 users and large
supports up to 5,000 users all this ad
nectar and this is a directory gateway
that allows you to proxy directory
requests to your on-premise Microsoft
Active Directory and this also comes in
two sizes small and large a small ad
connector is designed for small
organizations of up to 500 users and a
large ad connector is designed for
larger organizations for up to 5,000
users you can also use integrated
resource and deployment management tools
in your hybrid environment AWS provides
monitoring and management tools with
robust API s so you can easily integrate
your AWS resources of on-site tools and
most major software vendors already
support AWS like Microsoft VMware and
BMC tools such as AWS opsworks allow you
to deploy and operate applications in
the AWS cloud or in your own data center
you can use templates or build your own
tasks to specify an applications
architecture AWS code deploy automates
code deployments to instances in your
existing data center or in the AWS cloud
AWS code deploy simplifies the code
deployment process to your instances
this is the practice assignment for
designing hybrid storage where you'll
configure a basic plan to resolve an
on-premise storage problem you've been
hired by a medium-sized law firm who
have an aging storage solution that they
would like to replace but they do not
want to purchase any new hardware they
store several terabytes of data which is
comprised of documents and images a lot
of the data is legacy data which is
rarely accessed and can be archived
however the most recent files need to be
available instantly you have been tasked
with providing a very basic high-level
plan of a hybrid storage solution using
the clients existing data center and AWS
detail the products and services you
would use and sketch out a basic plan of
the infrastructure so let's review the
key takeaways from this lesson firstly
we learnt the AWS well architected
framework which helps you understand the
pros and cons of decisions you make
while buildings
and on AWS cloud infrastructure lets you
stop guessing your capacity needs it
allows you to test systems of production
scale it lowers the risk of architecture
change it automates to make
architectural experimentation easier and
allows for evolutionary architectures
the well architected framework is based
on four pillars security the ability to
protect information systems and assets
whilst delivering business value from
risk assessments and mitigation
strategies reliability the ability of a
system to recover from infrastructure or
service failures dynamically acquire
computing resources to meet demand and
mitigate disruptions such as miss
configurations or transient network
issues performance efficiency the
ability to use computing resources
efficiently to meet system requirements
and to maintain the efficiency as demand
changes and technologies evolve and cost
optimization optimization is the ability
to avoid or eliminate unneeded cost or
sub it to milk resources in the past
you'd have to estimate the peak load of
your systems and purchase hardware
accordingly cloud computing provides
virtually unlimited on-demand capacity
you can scale whenever you need to AWS
has plenty of features to make new
environment creation and automated and
repeatable process application should be
designed so they're broken into smaller
loosely coupled components AWS allows
you to make most of the security tools
and techniques you already know and
improve them by formalizing security
control design into your AWS platform
you can introduce redundancy so that
single points of failure in your system
are removed and AWS economies of scale
offers organizations huge opportunities
to make cost savings we look to Amazon
Cloud watch how it will monitor your AWS
resources and applications in real time
and collect and track metrics and send
alarms and notifications we looked at
cloud trail a web service that records
AWS API calls for your account and
stores and delivers this information for
an AWS config the fully managed service
that provides you with an AWS resource
inventory configuration history and
configuration change notifications we
looked at hybrid technologies so how you
can link your existing on-premise data
center with the Amazon Web Services
cloud you can extend your existing
on-premise network configuration onto
your AWS virtual private cloud so your
AWS resources operate as if they're part
of your existing network using Direct
Connect and VPC data integration and
lifecycle management is achieved through
storage gateway Amazon simple storage
service and Amazon Glacia I am is used
to control your Identity and Access
Management so you can secure your AWS
resources and you can use opsworks and
could deploy but integrated resource and
deployment management
this concludes designing highly
available cost efficient fault tolerant
scalable systems the next lesson is AWS
I am
you